yo what's up it's your boy blast you can
check me out on the bullet cat podcast
bootleg cab show special guest in here
just dropped a nice little four piece on
it
blast is back baby yes sir what's up
just for clarity out right now oh tap in
shout out alrighty shout out leg June
muster I feel like damn smart you and
Roddy Rich together is like uh it's like
the [__] Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
of like La hooks that's a good
compliment I like that I like that I
feel like people was waiting on this but
I feel like it was perfect perfect
timing too everybody was like when are
y'all gonna do a song together that was
like the one guy I feel like everybody
was like man a Roddy and blast record
would be [__] nuts yeah
perfect timing how does that work does
that work with like you send him the
record because I know you like to work
on your own usually at the house right
yeah well um I did a record already a
minute ago that I just produced actually
but um yeah I just sent them a beat pack
for this I sent it to Kiefer actually
they were sitting on it for a minute and
then Roddy was like I got something
perfect for us sent that through that
was the one passionate so how long ago
did you have the beat with Roddy because
you for people don't know I mean we talk
about this a lot but you're like an OG
out here for sure you obviously you've
you've taken off the last three or four
years but before that you were producing
a lot yeah for sure so I mean that's
pretty much how I got my name amongst
the city locally just producing like the
song for Kayla for real for real right
with it yep uh class most uh Beano's
early catalog but um the Roddy situation
I'm kind of tripping on the initial
question I was gonna say you said that
you had originally produced the beat for
Roddy back in the day oh yeah yeah just
being around organically how long ago
was that though that was probably four
years ago at this point because I knew
Roddy a minute and first time I met him
was in Compton in a Wilmington arms
projects just randomly he was like yo
you do music and I know his people you
know he just connected like that so just
to see his grind and see everything come
full circle like he's seen me before I
was anybody too and I feel like this was
a dope moment to you know link up but uh
they've been sitting on that beat for
like three four years oh damn so the
beat that you just dropped he he got
three years ago yeah oh [__] damn and
then you could tell too because the
sonics of the sound is like uh my six
tape one type Vibes like early things I
did with binos it's the same type of
Sonics and now okay so the original beat
that you produce for him did that ever
come out no it never came out never even
dropped whole different vibe too that
was a whole different vibe but never
came up yeah yeah well look man I do
feel like you kind of have you do make
timeless music so
three or four year old song still sounds
good absolutely now the song
the song was recorded more recently but
but the beat was made three or four
years ago there you go there you go are
you still recording at home a lot
absolutely I feel like like I'm used to
recording that I don't know that's like
my safe space you know how to engineer
yourself yeah if it ain't broke why fix
it so like will you like if you're out
of town and you go to the studio are you
like sitting at the board recording
yourself or do you use the other
Engineers from the studio yeah I still
you know open myself to work with other
engineers and things like that I got a
couple that I work with uh shout out to
the Lance shout out Chris at Paramount
but um
for the most part yeah I'm outside the
booth I'm sitting like this with them
you know I need that genuine authentic
connection when I'm recording and it
feels like I'm at home when I record
like that versus standing in the booth
and feeling disconnected with the you
know
I know you had said uh before that you
were recording a lot of these early
records on just that road like kit that
you would get at Guitar Center yeah if
you're at Paramount what mic you picking
see I'm not even that tapped into the
names and stuff but I like the Norman
u87 Mike that's what I just got hit
though too shout out tick he just bought
me that mic it's a great mic it's like a
three thousand dollar mic yeah I love it
that's it there's that one and then I
think the other one Everyone likes is
the the C800 the Sony that big black the
black one yeah yeah with the big booty
on the back yeah for sure
how often like okay you I feel like
you've had a pretty insane run when we
think about just some of the Legends
you've been able to record with you've
been on records with nas Rick Ross we
can go on and on and on
um how often are you able to kind of
like step out of the moment and kind of
appreciate the journey that you've been
on and just the last three or four years
it's been crazy to see yeah I don't
think I ever
well
this far as far as I've been recording I
don't feel like I ever got to that
moment
because I feel like I'm still living a
dream but like I can't even
Nas is Like my uncle's favorite rapper
You Feel Me Kendrick is like right my
favorite rapper so it's like all this
[__] is unreal I'm still trying to
unpack it all still trying to create a
name for myself still setting my
Foundation my infrastructure so it's
just I don't know I just look at it as
reinsurance you know that I'm
that I want to right path of everything
I love it man how um for you like I feel
like
you're still like popping in on people's
projects but I feel like
the last like six months or so you've
been a little quiet on like getting on
other people's [__] is it because you're
in album mode yes definitely an album
okay we cooking up I've been on tour
hella you're on tour yeah you feel me so
I went to Australia for the first time
how was we did a run out there Melbourne
is crazy I heard that that's the best
city I ever been to so far I heard all
the women look like Iggy
I actually hear that and I actually
listen I have friends who have gone
there who are African-American and they
say if you look like us you're getting
all the [__] I can't vouch for a lot
but uh they did treat us like royalty
out here
and uh they they just embraced the LA
culture too I feel like they knew about
artists like Kailyn yeah for real for
reals it was a group of girls like that
to me like where Kailyn at really oh
[__] that's correct that's how they said
it yeah I can't do the accent but I'm
not feeling a little crazy trying to do
it either is it I heard if you say
Melbourne they get mad it's supposed to
be like Melbourne Melbourne Melbourne
yeah I'll make sure I say it the right
way Jesus put some respect on them so
you were just in Australia living your
best life yeah we did Australia run we
did like five four or five cities out
there how was the food in Australia is
it the same is it kind of like just
America but like
not I I really don't recall
we was in and out you feel me in terms
of the vibe of Australia is it like an
American Vibe or is it like do you feel
like you're in like a whole other place
you definitely feel like you're in a
whole different place yeah just even
driving by certain sides or buildings
the infrastructures are buildings
everything just looked different so
Melbourne is your favorite City you've
been to yeah so far just the people
outside of everything just the way they
Embrace this the way they actually
genuinely was fans we did like an after
party after it was cracking like
everybody that came to the show was at
the after party too it was lit any tour
stuff coming up this year uh it's gonna
be a light year I feel like I I
definitely
am dedicating this year to be more
creative you feel me finishing my debut
album yeah but I'm gonna do select dates
different festivals and
College shows things like that so I'm
still outside but we're not even
considering you having any albums out
yet
I feel like I have it put out an album
yet like I haven't sat down and
genuinely been like album mode
everything I've been making been on the
move so like now you put out the four
pack just to kind of appease everybody
you're like yo I got these four where
you did it before obviously yeah uh this
is kind of the appetizer to the debut
albums the appetizer and you can tell
too I'm staying true to my sound right
but for the for the album it's gonna be
more experimental I'm definitely still
staying true to myself for the album too
but it's the elevated version of that so
I'm excited for the fans because I feel
like they can predict what I'm doing but
I'm gonna hit them with a left jab real
quick I was gonna say how are you
experimenting because I do feel like
you have your signature sound yeah you
have your I feel like you have your
pocket if we think of like what a blast
BPM is like we kind of know what your
pocket is how are you expanding the
sound how are you experimenting man well
for me it's just opening my mind to
different creators as well right A lot
of the times I'll be in the house by
myself like it's only so much
inspiration you can pull from a bedroom
in isolation right right so I'm opening
uh my mind with different writers
different producers different creatives
even just people with good conversation
I'm just you know putting myself more
out there I'll be to myself a lot so you
know it's a challenge for me but I'm
willing to go over that hump would you
say you're an introvert
uh I'm like an introverted extrovert
like if you know me you know I'm goofy
you know I'm actually talking and
playful but you know the people I'm not
really comfortable with it may take some
time for me to get open with you you and
Riley Rich are very similar definitely
yeah yeah we just we just shot the video
to passionate and it was like y'all got
to open up more he was like you know we
two [__] Turn Down video
shout out right here that's good people
yo this is an amazing jacket shout out
to Jeff Hamilton you said this is a
custom jacket Hamilton Jeff Hamilton man
we did a you know a custom piece for the
before you go to our merch so fans
bought this too yeah what's that at
least a rack 1200 1500. you feel that
leather man no I know listen I know
regular daggling he made his son's
jacket and I put it on at my boy shop
guest list in Phoenix
and then he was like it's 1200 and I
took it right off and put it back I said
that shout out to Jeff man shout out
Jeff man he good people yeah um for you
how are you guys expanding the Eagle
brand because if it's going to be kind
of a quiet year for you after this four
pack working on the album or you guys uh
gonna be putting out artists I know
we've talked to you guys have had you
guys signed artists obviously we talked
about that last time is there going to
be any music coming out it's gonna be a
lot of things coming out as Vic likes
likes to say we like to keep the channel
noisy right so we got the Venture side
of Eagle we got the publish inside of
Eagle we got the label side
um we got artists like Jay million that
we developing we got producers and
artists like Grandmaster Vic Jay pilot
so we pushing them out in different
Endeavors as well they're gonna be
working on my project too but um and
then we got the you know the investment
side of things we we heavy on that side
too uh what are you guys investing in we
got the creative wreck in Philly okay
what's that um Philly wreck Philly it's
the Creator for gems I mean it's a gym
for creators my bad so when you say it's
a gym for creatives yeah it's like where
people who are creative go to like lift
weights
it's like it's like a workshop for
creators so you may go in you may want
to yo you could come here you could lift
weights No One's Gonna judge you if you
got paint on your hands and [__]
nah it's like a gym for Creative so when
I say that it's like a workshop where
you may link with somebody who know how
to print up some merch or you may link
with somebody who's a producer or you
know somebody
yeah so it's like the hub for that but
they also just partnered with uh with
Diddy for Miami wreck as well so you're
a part of that or you're just part of
the Philly location we part of the whole
thing oh yeah yeah so check you out in
business with Diddy kind of yes
literally you could say that have you
ever talked to Diddy no not personally
why not
I mean never it's just you're blast it
hasn't been hard to encountered yet what
are you talking about I'm pretty sure
we're gonna run into each other someday
he's supposed to be putting out an r b
album man he's going crazy with Jazzy
too
love records they going stupid you got
to be on the Diddy r b album yeah I work
with Jazzy shout out Jazzy have you uh
because I do feel like you're kind of
like
when we think of like West Coast the
last five years or so it's really like
you and Roddy rich in terms of
Commercial Success
um do you feel like really I really I
mean commercials we leave out Tyler the
Creator yeah you're right [__] everyone
does that including me apparently I
would say this is literally Tyler yeah
and then Tyler we gotta put Tyler number
one on those I just got to say I've just
seen him his own Festival that dramas
listening party and I was like bro every
time we speak about the West I don't
know why people leave your name I don't
even like mentally see him as a even
like I didn't mention Kendrick right now
I guess I'm thinking like I don't know
she's the OG though yeah I understand
what you said I'm talking about like the
new generation like I feel like you and
Roddy have obviously each kind of hit
your stride in the last five years but
do you feel uh do you feel like the
pressure of like kind of like
because when we think of La I think a
lot of people who aren't from LA
feel like La has a certain sound that
isn't necessarily palatable Nationwide a
lot but then you got guys like yourself
and Roddy who come through and are
making these like anthems that everybody
all over the world are being able to
like consume and like do you feel like
any pressure in terms of just
representing the West on that scale or
do you not even think about it you're
just making music I don't even think I
don't even think that deep into it I
just do me for the most part but I get
it though you know but I also feel like
it starts with the producers as well
like we we have a certain Sonic that we
are you know like not letting go at all
so we just got to get more experimental
and the producers got to be more mindful
of that as well and also collaborating
with the artists got a collaborative
producers outside of La yeah that part
get on them YouTube beats man that
attributes a lot to righty success you
feel me they couldn't box a man from the
jump so you can't predict what he's
gonna do it's bootleg cab here gotta
stop the interview to tell you about our
good friends at King Palm now listen
guys all I do is smoke out of King Palm
if you see me smoking it's out of King
Palm all right and I'm gonna shout them
out because it's all natural
no tobacco to tobacco-free uh product
also no additives no need to split it
open no need to lick it comes ready to
go all you have to do
is put your uh your tree your flower of
choice right into here and you're good
to go now the best thing about King Palm
they have these turbine enough infused
wraps right here they're flavored uh
this is my favorite I do love watermelon
all right burst of watermelon flavor
again no tobacco no additives all
natural all you got to do is pack it and
you aren't ready to go now this is
what's dope about King Palm if you go to
the website right now you know they're
the new sponsor I've been using them
forever so I had to hit them up like hey
guys I'm tired of smoking your guys's
[__] I'd love some support on the
podcast like of course all right so go
to kingpom.com right now use the promo
code bootleg Kev and You're Gonna Save
50 off
um you can get whatever you need you can
order it online because these are
tobacco free no nicotine baby all right
so you can get it right to your house
half off kingpom.com keyword bootleg
heavy you can also hit your local
7-Eleven you could also hit your local
smoke shop one of the best selling
brands in America at the smoke shop so
many different products rollable wraps
hemp cones all the smoking accessories
one would ever need the smoothest smoke
the easiest to use
what are you [__] doing if you're
smoking and you're smoking at anything
but this you're [__] crazy all right
go check them out online socials one
more time kingpom.com promo code bootleg
save half off taking you on that natural
path King pong baby hey also shout out
to the homies at Blue chew man don't
forget if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction if you're a penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather bluetooth's where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra anacialis but it's
in a chewable form all right it is sent
right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a Bluetooth use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free also got a shout out to my bookie
man Final Four Is On The Way NBA
playoffs are here well almost here we
got like a few games left right so much
going on you got the Masters coming up
man so many ways to win money
join us in my bookie I've been using my
bookie for about a decade now it's where
I put all my bets in uh there's so many
ways to win money with my bookie if you
go to my bookie right now you sign up
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg and you
will get double deposit bonus action
that means your very first deposit up to
a thousand dollars make that deposit
with that promo code bootleg when you
sign up for that new account and they're
going to give you uh uh another thousand
dollars they're gonna double your first
deposit so you might put 200 in you
might put 500 in they will give you
another 200 another 500 to gamble with
all right so much to do with my bookie
obviously we love betting on sports
literally one of my biggest passions in
life is gambling away my money and
winning money on mybookie.ag now I got a
few Futures going on right now I got
Joelle embed doing the MVP I got the
Phoenix Suns to win the West I got the
Bucks to win the East NCAA action I'm
taking UConn all the way what are y'all
doing go to my bookie right now they got
the props you can do the player props
you can do the over unders you can do
whatever you need plus live Blackjack
live roulette I have so much fun on my
bookie you really don't ever need to
leave your house
shout out to my booking mybookie.ag sign
up right now with the promo code bootleg
and get that first deposit bonus
what are we talking about who else is
going to double your first deposit
ladies and gentlemen mybookie.ag promo
code bootleg sign up and let's win some
money now let's get back to the
interview has anybody made any blast
hooks through artificial intelligence
yet the AI have you seen this I've seen
that you talking about like well you
could like I saw this verse he just did
a whole verse he wrapped it as himself
like he was Kanye and then he ran it
through artificial intelligence and it's
it sounds like a [__] Kanye song yeah
so people can literally be out here with
bootleg blast verses I swear it'll be
probably it's probably easier with raps
but like singing I don't know man
artists we should find out a singer AI
singer if someone like
hypothetical situation somebody puts up
a fake blast record yeah and it goes
crazy yeah right they write it they sing
it then they put their own verses on it
it goes crazy though
are you making them take it down
I mean if I could be a part of it let's
get this back okay okay
I'm not gonna hate on it but I got to be
a part of it for sure do you ever look
up blast type beats on YouTube yeah I do
ever anything fire yeah you may come
across some
I always wondered that like I'm like yo
if I'm a rapper I'm just like type
beating myself on YouTube I'll pause
all the time
you got a sick mind man no I'm just
saying I mean [__] I can't talk about
beating myself on the internet nah nah I
don't I don't think it's like I feel
like you got to go to the originator for
that for the blast type beats you know
but shout out to all the producers
that's you know taking the sauce and
running with it would you say uh in 2023
because I do feel like being a producer
it's a very heavily saturated game
and unfortunately as a producer I feel
like you're kind of underappreciated in
the same way that photographers and
videographers are underappreciated in
the hip-hop producers the same way like
what would be some advice you would give
producers in 2023 whether it's having
their business right or
you know I think some people chase
placements as opposed to like
you know there's other routes to
monetize your talent you know what I
love and shout out to hit boy because I
feel like he's
pinpointing this but like producers that
work with that artist and just build a
whole sound a whole Sonic like what he
did with Benny The Butcher and what he
doing with knives things like that I
feel like we need to get back to that
like Timberland and Missy Elliott like
we don't really get those full bodies of
work like that so that's what I'm like
if you're an up-and-coming producer in
like Indiana or something like find a
dope artist that's in your city and like
try to build a sound I think that's
Doper than just getting that one hit
record with that popular artist already
it's like it's better when you build
something from the from the mud well you
checked uh Roddy off the list of artists
that people want to see you work with is
there anybody else you really want to
work with it for whatever reason it just
hasn't aligned yet uh
nobody specifically I mean I always say
for real but that's like more so I want
him to Executive produce a project later
down the line if if I'm able to if he's
able to but uh nobody specifically right
now I'm trying to focus on myself yeah
nobody on the r b side
nah I pretty much work with a lot of
people I gotta get back to the Blast
story you've been on channel recently
for sure yeah I mean I've been going
through I've been I've been feeling like
T-Pain last year
feature crazy feature crazy nowadays
let's say major label calls some it's a
new artist they signed you have no idea
who it is but they're on Atlantic and
they want that blast sauce that [__]
what's that heading for uh you know I
never charge for a future ever ever no
really
so you're doing it only if you truly
want if I truly like the song you have
to like the song you have to like the
artist yeah I'm talking about up front
it's a backhand cause but if I like the
song I'm not going to give you that
hassle you feel me the back end is just
like uh the bag or is it the maybe maybe
the video the club it may be the the
Wardrobe for the video things of that
nature you feel me you still gotta show
up as blast I'm still a brand I'm still
a company but on the front end I'm not
going to be like I need 15 just to
record the first I need you know yo it
sucks too because a lot of artists will
pay that to these features and then this
song doesn't get clear yeah
just take out the money already hey hey
get your money how you get it couldn't
be me though what about you and T Payne
that'll be crazy hmm I love T-pain have
you seen his uh any of his covers he
just did a whole cover album yeah I've
been watching that he didn't get the uh
um Ozzy Osbourne War Pigs yeah he did uh
he did a lot Sam Cook Sam Cook he did
Chris Stapleton the country guy
oh come in yeah T-Pain a legend you guys
have never connected never can I think
we were supposed to I think I know his
manager actually but
never got on the table officially you
gotta make that happen man yeah cause
you're kind of like the Hook guy now you
know yeah I need some songs I need to
ask him a thousand questions when I did
the video with Rick Ross I asked him a
thousand questions what questions did
you ask Rick Ross I was like what did
you do with your first million what do
you say it was like first thing I did I
saved it
but he was telling me he was like
because I told him I lived in L.A he was
like that's the worst place to buy real
estate get something in Atlanta Atlantis
for sale it's a lot of land so also the
state taxes here suck yeah
tell me about it are you realizing that
now that you're rich
I wouldn't say that but you got that guy
Vic over there who'll give you some
terrible tax advice according to town
you know
he cleared it up on the last interview
you know what you got to do you got to
set up the address in Nevada
buy a house out there
just let it sit or just have some people
rent it but all the bills are in your
name hey I'll take all the advice and
then you paste no state tax because
Nevada's that's what you do
no but a rapper who you have a lot of
songs with does that
um yeah
he's from L.A he likes a lot of songs
more than two no I think you only have
one or two with them okay I think ish
whatever yeah not a lot of songs
speaking of a lot of songs have you
talked to mozzie have you wrote him
since he's been in jail or I haven't
haven't talked to Mazi free Mozzy man I
talked to davo though and uh he said you
know he in good spirits so when he gets
out I think you guys should do another
like dude just the clarity three just
all mozzie features that'll be crazy and
I definitely want to check that off my
list sooner and later like a Mozzy some
type of project whether it be four songs
10 songs something because I feel like
the chemistry we got we ain't missed yet
I feel like too Mozzy was like an early
believer in you in terms of like just
like collaborating and and you know I
feel like mozzie has a huge following
and yeah like he he put you on some [__]
that you know at that time I remember a
lot of people found you through mozzie
definitely shout out Devo for really
making a play but I always say between
mozzie and Eric Bellinger that was first
two artists that that gave me that
platform what did Eric do for you he
gave me a feature early this was before
bino Eric's great yeah he gave me a hug
early on he gave you a hook early yeah
just just threw it to you well we
swapped you know I gave him a hook as
well has he put yours out yeah okay I
didn't know if he was like holding on to
it because I'd be hearing random hooks
or yours that are like four years old
when rappers play me songs I'd be like
yeah I got a record of a blast I'm like
oh [__] like yeah we did this in like
2017 right right right why haven't you
released it
do you ever like have to take [__] down
online because it's old or unauthorized
I did that earlier I did that earlier I
had a lot of you know
unpolished music up and I felt like as a
brand it wasn't you know I mean I mean
like an artist who maybe has had a hook
for like oh no no no well
I don't nothing I've never had to drop
maybe once the cease and desist on
somebody not nah I feel like we a
tight-knit company we don't really leak
too much or we have a small circle
anyway as far as the creative team so
none of that ever happened to me I did
try to leak the uh
passionate record of me and Roddy before
it came out this was like two days
before it came out really yeah but it
was also on the insecure show
like maybe a month or two probably so
somebody had it it's been through a lot
of hands yeah it was yeah
but we got it under control yeah once
it's on a TV show who knows how many
people have touched the song or had it
in their email at that point yeah pretty
much damn I remember I used to shout out
I got my name because I used to get the
leaks online and so you made a whole
brand off of it stealing me you got five
rooms 17 Studios and everything he doing
a bit you the rich one no no no no no
you're the rich one ever since you got
that that uh Platinum plaque look at
that you've been running up the bag yeah
what's the next song that's about to
that I can get a plaque for what what's
the next song You Gotta Have Some More
certifications you gotta have the uh
the Die Hard black that'll be legendary
me and Kim have they have they done
plaques for that no not yet
not yet
that's a legendary situation right there
I'm excited for that one is it already
Platinum hey
we can look it up and do the math but
I have it
yo I want to say when I was you came out
did you come out with Kendrick at staple
or at crypto I didn't okay yeah maybe
that's what maybe I remember being
disappointed that you didn't because I
went to I went to two of the shows I was
there though that show was legendary I
was like this would be a great
opportunity to bring Blast out but it
was such a like very unique set I feel
like it'd be kind of weird to like
Implement like a yeah you know because
the way that show was it was so like
well yeah choreography and it was very
yeah and I was on tour at the same time
too we actually performed in London I
want to say back-to-back dates like and
his venue was right across the street
from mine the O2 did he give you any
advice in terms of like you know Rick
Ross told you to move out of California
did Kendrick ever give me the Kendrick
alone I'm gonna hit him when when I
really really really need his advice but
I know he'd be in his own world so I'm
gonna treat that relationship sacredly
there it is man hey we gotta stop the
interview real quick to tell you about
our family at Odd Socks baby that's
right shout out to Odd Socks little
Godfather sock right there craziest
licenses in the game the most
comfortable socks period And if you go
to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg you're gonna get
20 off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws pop these boys open
check them out
oh yeah oh yeah a little Chun Lee versus
Blanco
what
amazing
do you like you who so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet I promise
you you gotta go to autotoxofficial.com
right now and use the promo code bootleg
save 20 off your entire order alright so
go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Jardin the craziest
dispenser you've ever walked into in
your life Harding Las Vegas you gotta
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you gotta go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Hardy underscore Las Vegas check out
more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview so uh album on the way the
four pack is out now
you got a song with Larry June yeah
who's been killing [__]
um how long have you been hip to Larry's
movement because he's been man for the
better part of the last 10 years
building an independent Powerhouse right
I actually got put on The Late General
from from Vic yeah he put me on to his
music and I really just liked how he
branded everything his aesthetic the
organic or it's all very consistent
yours is too though you guys are very
purposeful in terms of The Branding and
the aesthetic of all your me I feel like
all your art everything just flows
together right and I feel like it was
only right and I pay attention to the
comments too as far as like with the
fans be wanting from your stuff and they
always preached about lady June I got a
heavy fan base in the bay so it was
perfect you guys do a swap no we didn't
we didn't not yet yeah you gotta do one
for him now yeah that's inevitable we
definitely gonna cook up some more even
he just be he just popped out of my uh
Jay's residency at the vet in Vegas
right I forgot you're doing trades now
yeah you're rich
what are we talking about you're at you
gotta drink they don't be giving Dre's
residencies to know lightweights out
here
we building the relationships that's all
I could say how is it like doing because
I I've been to Dre's a million times
and when you perform at drays you're
performing for your fans but you're also
performing for just like tourists that
are in town right so is it different
like when you do a Dre show like how
because is it kind of like doing a club
show or is it because it's like writing
yeah it's like that pocket right in the
middle of a like an actual show in a
club show but the crowd it felt like it
was nothing but blacks fans up in there
the way that was screaming word for work
how often are you doing it well we just
did the first one
um earlier this year I have another
Resident residency out there right now
daylight but we cooking up right now
we're just building a relationship for
the most part you gamble when you're in
Vegas
slightly I'll be at the tables what do
you play though I'll shoot crabs crabs
is the best funnest game yeah you could
win really it's not fun when you're
losing though because you could lose
fast exactly man crap so yeah you'll be
[__] on a run and they'd be like let
me buy all the [__] numbers yeah
that's seven inch I'm still yeah I'm
still a student though so I you know I
play say I have like you know who's
really good at craps who taught me was
DJ head he's a degenerate Gambler he
will never let that picture him gambling
of course not because he's perfect but
he is a he that is his one black market
we got something on him he's a gambler
yeah [__] you got the crap table
it's like watching Tiger Woods play golf
that's crazy I I just I never knew how
to play crabs until me and head went to
Vegas and it was like watching art yeah
he's amazing at craps I don't know if
you could be good at craps but he was
yeah yeah craps is fun that's great I
cannot picture DJ head gambling you've
been in any Vegas strip clubs not at all
you gotta go I stay away from strip
clubs why
just a smart thing to do save your
dollars no you go and you eat
you go and eat you got to go and get the
chicken wings I don't eat chicken see I
don't got no reason at the club yeah
vegan something like that what's that
mean a vegan are you vegan I'm uh I'm a
picky eater I'm tired of the titles you
hear me I feel like you don't eat
chicken no I don't I haven't ate chicken
in probably like 12 years why so good so
where do you get your protein from
it's a lot of yeah we're not even finna
dive all the way do you eat fish where
do cows get their protein from what
about gorillas
this guy's [__] this guy right here
is the same he's like yeah you tell him
[__]
so you don't eat fish or anything yeah
you fish occasionally that's like the
only thing I go to as far as when's the
last time you had a steak
I don't think I ever had a steak in my
life oh yeah I've never liked even as a
kid a poor guy and like too chewy you
don't you never had in and out
yeah I probably had it now when I was
younger
if you don't eat burgers veggie burgers
it's the same thing it's 20 23. you're
trying to tell me a veggie burger that
tastes like ass cheeks is the same you
ever have Burger guys nobody wants none
of that [__] shut up Burger guys
black independent shout out to them
support them they going crazy
fire better than in and out better than
everything you're a [__] liar don't
tell people that this is crazy this is
I'm serious try it so you okay on a
daily basis you wait like are you eating
salads all [__] day peanut butter
what are you eating
uh I eat everything you a regular person
would eat is just a veggie style a lot
of potato chips a lot of cereal I am a
heavy potato chip eater unfortunately
that's what's your favorite choice
I like hot Cheetos that's just gonna
[__] you up it will you won't need a
steak but you can eat that [__] I
know yeah tell me about it what do you
think is worse for you the steak is a
[__] hot cheese steak you're [__]
crazy what about do you eat a lot of
cereal
I don't eat cereal at all never in life
no I'm more of a fruit guy before Syria
as a kid you didn't eat cereal yeah
growing up I ate you know you never
busted cinnamon toast 9 p.m bowl of
Lucky Charms nah I'm a noodles type of
guy like Ramen 12 a.m 12 a.m bust out
the pack yeah do you have anything
special with the noodles are we putting
any sort of hot sauce or cheese or
anything nah you're going too crazy
we're not in jail now we're gonna eat
them regular we're making a spread we
gotta get you some cereal and some steak
what's your favorite cereal ever
it goes back and forth I got three who's
the one with the frog on it that used to
be Fox smacks I love uh I like peanut
butter crunch even though it [__] the
roof of your mouth up yeah I like Apple
Jacks and Lucky Charms
everything was sugar
let's say you used to put the extra
sugar you know how people put that only
in Cheerios you get the norm the regular
Cheerios you put the sugar in it yeah
that's real ghetto is it getting real
unhealthy you eat hot cheetos I don't
want to hear steak Yeah
steak is good it's dead
well I mean you would rather me bite a
live Cow's Ass you know I actually I
don't judge you have a [__] lettuce
the dead cow on his [__] coat right
now Hamilton
come on now you're too good to eat it
but you'll wear the cow this is Jeff
Hamilton it's different it's premium
you're you know what you are you're a
hypocrite you're right I am all right
well listen man I'm human that's what I
am everybody's a hypocrite yeah look we
got to get you on some [__] meat bruh
pause you know what I mean nobody y'all
have a good day last uh the new single
with Roddy rich is out everywhere
requested obviously the four pack is out
um just for clarity two absolutely album
before the end of the year it's or we
don't know yet we don't know yet it's
very methodical yeah yeah yeah too early
we're gonna be in your face though
regardless pause okay and uh is the
video was everybody out yet
no it's not it's dropping real soon did
you direct it
I did not um
direct Dev There It Is Well look go
support this guy
um we need to start a GoFundMe for him
to be better we just all need to just
get you some kobe beef yeah you're rich
we don't need to give you a GoFundMe we
need to take you to a nice steakhouse
cereal fun Vic are you on the same level
good at least not everyone in your
team's insane
yeah
fish okay yeah
you gotta get the steak buddy picky
eater you like chicken nuggets hell no
vegan chicken nuggets hell yeah that
[__] is
that [__] is crazy to me that [__] it
tastes like [__] first of all they
can't coach I'm tired of these vegan
[__] calling things vegan something
yeah like vegan chicken wings it's too
Politico for sure just call it like a
chickpea ball it's not a [__] chicken
anyway that's how we end the interview
guys dietary yeah my guy I appreciate
you brother appreciate it yes sir